no matter which holiday you celebrate  December is a month for gifts and sony  has more PlayStation Plus freebies for  you I'm Tony this is a game spot news  update and this is your free December  games lineup first up ps4 is getting the  stealthy tactics game invisible ink and  the stylish isometric RPG stories the  path of destinies ps3 is getting two  shooters the spacefaring hyper void and  the cutesy little tiny troopers joint  ops the latter can also be played on  Vita thanks to cross by Sony's handheld  is also getting the indie platformer  vvvvvv and the fast-paced side scroller  color guardians and that one will also  be playable on ps4 with cross by so yeah  you have a lot of options this month the  new games will be available when the PSN  store refreshes on Tuesday december six  until then you can grab November's free  games like the deadly Tower of monsters  or everybody's gone to the rapture for  all the latest on PlayStation you're  already in the right place